hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar constructing a spatially
resolved single cell atlas of the mouse
retina with the mirror scope platform
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by visgen
to learn more visit visjan.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
ray ten director atc single cell
genomics core
baylor college of medicine
professor hgsc
departments of molecular and human
genetics baylor college of medicine
dr chen you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone uh thank you very much
for the introduction uh it's really my
great pleasure to be here to share with
you what we're doing here at wiston
so for today's presentation i hope to
first give a quick overview of our
platform and illustrate how you can
apply this technology to really gather
new biological insights and map the
future with spatial genomics
so
as many of us know um biological tissues
are very complex and made of many
different cell types that express genes
very differently and understanding that
gene expression profile within each cell
and across the tissue is very critical
for better understanding of the
biological system
so over the past two or three decades we
have seen a revolution in genomics
research which really enables us to
characterize different biological
systems at unprecedented scale and
resolution
as you can see from this landscape of
genomic evolution are shown here from
bulk rna sequencing to single cell
sequencing but we can now interrogate
the gene expression profile of
individual cells and really use this
information to understand cell
composition and cell cell interactions
now
however sequencing based approaches have
a fundamental limitation because
they don't usually provide the special
context of what you're looking at to do
the sequencing cells either have to be
destroyed or dissociated and thus will
lose the very rich spatial information
for the 3d tissue structure
and as many biological problems do
require multiplex specially resolved
single cell measurements we see a huge
demand for technologies that can satisfy
these criteria and that's what we are
working on within wisdom
so specifically we are commercializing a
technology called murfish that enables
in-situ single-cell transcriptome
profiling and our commercial product
merscope picture here is the complete
platform solution for murfish technology
so murfish stands for multiplexed aero
robust fluorescence in situ
hybridization so this is a rna imaging
based technique that can locate and
quantify hundreds to thousands of
different rna species at the same time
with subcellular resolution
so as illustrated on this slide there
are three key aspects that makes this
highly multiplexed approach possible
which are completely labeling sequential
imaging and aero robust barcoding
so to perform murfish we use a type of
oligopoles which contains different
particles to label
the different rna species
then each barcode is fluorescently
detected in sequential round of imaging
and the optical barcode generated from
these many rounds of imaging with one
indicating fluorescent on and zero
indicating fluorescent off then this
will this optical barcode will help to
resolve different rna species
and in the end it will generate a
specially resolved rna profiling data
and
in the end it will give a fiscal picture
for the cell or tissue of interest as
illustrated by the picture on the right
with colored dots indicating different
rna species and grain lines indicating
the cell boundary
the mercies was invented by our
scientific co-founder dr xiaowei juan at
harvard university back in 2015 and
since the initial publication in the
journal of science it has been validated
by not only for publications and brought
many transformers to transformative
discoveries already and actually
specially resolved transcriptomics was
selected as method of the year in 2020
by natural methods and murphys was
featured though really highlighting the
excitement it has already generated
so to make this powerful technology more
broadly available we are commercializing
murfrees through our commercial platform
called merscope and this platform
facilitates the whole murfish
measurement with a complete reagent
instrument and software solution
upstream we have the ready to use
murphy's gym panel and sample prep
reagents to sand the samples
then the processed samples will be noted
onto the turnkey instrument for imaging
and we also have software tools to
facilitate the data analysis and
visualization
so as a targeted rna imaging technology
first you need to sand the samples with
the gene panel and then the tissue and
scissors then will be noted to the
merscope uh flow chamber and put
together uh there are associate reagent
paths that goes with the sample then it
will be noted to the merscope machine
and as illustrated on this night
vertical path very large image of area
up to one square centimeter with imaging
resolution down to 100 nanometers
so with that the instrument will
automatically apply the data and
transfer the data to uh
with that
the instrument will automatically
acquire the data and then transfer the
data to the imaging processing computer
for analysis as illustrated by the
wisdom data flow for murfish here on
this slide
so there are five different data outputs
coming out of merscope
analysis the first one is the list of
all detected transcripts
which contains the gene counts and then
the xyz coordinates the second one is
the mosaic images which contains the
darpy and total
mrna staining as well as some other
protein standing images in the t format
then the third one transcripts per cell
metrics is a format very similar to what
single cell rna thick that output looks
like which contains the gn cell matrix
and finally we do provide cell metadata
that contains the x y coordinates of the
cell as the polygon shape of the cell
boundaries in hdf5 format
so you can use software package such as
scanpi or serrat to analyze the data uh
and alternatively we have also developed
merscope visualizer to facilitate the
analysis and visualization as well as
illustrated by this side here
so as a gene expression profiling tool
merscope at its basic phone just reports
the location and quantities of rna
species as well as the cell boundary
information but with so much information
it opens up many application areas and
with envision it can be broadly used in
many research areas as well on this
slide for example you can use this to
profile the gene expression in situ
classify and discover cell types and
states and reveal the cellular structure
and organization within native tissue
context or even profile the cellular
activity
for example shown on this slide this is
using a panel 500 around
500 genes
to profile the mouse uh gpsr and rtk
receptors in the mouse brain and you can
see that this is a highly quantitative
and highly reproducible measurement um
from the left you're seeing the eight
rna subset out of this 480 string
measurement while in the middle you are
seeing the gene expression within single
cells
so this has also been used in more
clinically relevant samples for example
shown here is using a panel of 417 genes
in human colon cancer and again which is
only 10 rna subjects selected out of
these 417 genes there is already a lot
of biological insights that you can
gather from such a single measurement
so with invision we keep pushing the
limit of the technology by expanding the
application areas we have proven
murfrees in more than 20 different mouse
and human tissues and a few
representative tissue types are shown on
this side and i hope that these
beautiful images illustrate how
incredible special architecture of
different tissue types have and how
important it is to have this highly
sensitive and versatile tool to profile
the gene expression and cell types
across different tissue types
and finally just to add on so murfish is
compatible on many different sample
types including adherent cells
suspended cells fresh and fixed frozen
tissue blocks as well
enough just to recap what i have just uh
shared uh here is a really quick summary
of some of the mercury advantages uh
first first group has very high
multiplexing power we can measure up to
uh a few hundreds to thousands of genes
simultaneously in a single sample
and secondly miroscope has very high
special resolution we can localize rna
transcripts with subcellular resolution
and that high special resolution is
preserved across the entire tissue
thirdly murphy has very high sensitivity
for identifying rna
in situ and it really enables us to
detect many low expressed but
functionally important genes very easily
furthermore meroscope has very high
cells throughput we can profile square
sentiment of tissue with hundreds of
thousands of cells and sometimes
millions of cells in a single experiment
and importantly no follow-up sequencing
is needed you get all the information in
a single experiment around without any
additional sequencing cost and finally
merscope is very flexible but we can
perform more fish of almost any tissue
or sample types
so in summary i hope this quick overview
uh this gives you a quick overview of
our past one and we're really excited
about the potential of our technology
and would love to hear how we could
potentially help with our uh help your
research with our platform and with that
i wanted to turn to dr chen
who will be sort of sharing his insights
in uc merscope and image the retina
tissue thank you
so first i'd like to thank for the
introduction and also like really happy
to have the opportunity to share with
you
about our experience with the merscope
platform and using this on-phone
technology to build single cell atlas of
the mouse retina
so our lab is
generally interested in the visual
system
in particularly the retina neural retina
which is at back of the eye that is this
is part of the organ that that captured
the light and converted light to
electric uh signal and and then
transmitted the eye to the brain
so this part of the neuroretinal tissue
is actually the leading
target for the irreversible blind
diseases
so although it's only how five major
neuron types uh in in the retina the
number of cell subtypes based on the
morphology and the physiology is quite
complex
so as has me estimated about 60 to 70
different subtypes exist in the human
retina
and add onto that complexity the
self-proportion of different subtypes
are quite different for example in
ganglion cells which make up about one
percent of the cell population is about
15 different types
quite interestingly the the mouse retina
seems to be even more complex than not
in human
so it has been shown based on a
transcriptome and other studies there's
over a hundred different sub subtypes
identified in the mouse retina
and this this is a umap based on single
cell rna seq of about a quarter million
single uh
most rectangular cells and we can see
all the major cell types can be
identified it's more than 100 subtypes
so this
single cell technology is really
wonderful that so now for the first time
we can identify all the subtypes however
what's missing is the spatial
information
just like if we think about directions
like a really nicely arranged fruit tray
uh what we have right now instead of
smoothie which we getting from box
sequencing
from single cell we can find all the
cell types and how many of the other or
the proportion however what's missing is
the spatial information which is very
critical for some standard function of
the retina
so there's recently there's many uh
especially rapid progression in the
single cell spatial transcription
technologies that can be used to get to
actually generate obtain that spatial
information at single cell resolution
there are
simply put there are two major types one
is the sequence-based type
method which is hybridization based but
the sequence based for example from the
of technology from 10x is something we
are quite familiar with
and today i will mainly focus on
hybridization based method particularly
murphy here
so uh dr john already uh
went through the background how the
murphys work so i will skip this slide
so we are actually lucky to be selected
as one of the early access sites for the
more scope so instead of the nice
looking box you see uh
uh dr you know presented what we have is
this basically the
the gut of the instrument there are two
major parts one is the image part here
and then this is the pump which it can
be used to automatically uh adding
probes and wash probes so you don't need
to be there all night long
so the workflow for us to
generate the uh spatial
map for the retina is as follows so we
start off as a you know a nuclear eye
and then we make a fresh frozen tissue
and make we make a 10 micron section so
and from slide and the slide is
is slightly fixed and the
hybridized to a probe of 386
in our case that's select from the
single cell ionization for cell markers
and then in parallel we actually also
add a few antibodies that highlight the
three antibodies highlight the cell
boundary
so after this the vibration staining and
they go through a multiple round of
imaging to basically decode the probe
and so we can identify which which
transcript are in the tissue
so here
i show a
you know basically raw data what you can
see is the the the white box are
basically diabetes training for the
nuclei as you can see the the retina of
the mouse has three layers autonuclear
layer inner nuclear layer and rtc's
so uh and then you can see a cloud of
colors hovering around it and then what
happens is you see you know for the
regions that basically on top of the
nuclear region you have more dense
signal well the layers between the two
nuclei layer are much less those are the
plaques layer which are basically
synapse forming and which makes sense to
have less transcript
so if we look closely we start looking
at the
marker
marker probe microtransfer expression so
what's shown here this is the outer
nuclear layer of the retina and you can
see the the the cells that are
highlighted by the yellow lines those
are kong cells because we know that
because you will see many probe that
specifically cones are highly expressed
in there you do see a few individual red
dots
those are likely to be basically
background
so if we look at the
the probes against the rod of markers
you can see all the rest of the cells
are are other red cells and then the
cone cells in fact um
shitty at the top layer
of the the
retina which is exactly where
based on previous results no it's
consistent with that reduction
similarly we'll look at the bipolar
cells which are interneurons connect the
photoreceptor cells to rdc layers as you
can see there's a 10 pc vc marker
bipolar cell markers highlight the top
half of the
nuclear layer
and this is a zoom in
and then if you overlay that with the
subtype of bipolar cells like on off and
rbc's you can see
unlike the yellow dots the other
color dots have a specific pattern that
basically highlights different subtypes
so uh what that looks like so we we
first look at how robust is the
technology so we did two value to
replicate regular one and two and we
just look at the uh value of the
transcript value across the entire slide
that so you can see they're highly
reproducible with r square of 0.94
and then we're also looking at you know
whether this robust result the murphy's
results are consistent with the single
from the rn-6 data so we take this same
retina and we do bob iron sequencing and
we compare the murphy count as you can
see where
nicely positive correlated concordance
are between these two technologies
so of course now with the transcript you
know identify the image issue to the
next steps to assign the the transcript
to the cell so to do that we need to
first segment the cell and then identify
the cell boundary
so as you can see in the left
panel is basically uh the white lines
are cell boundary and very staining
as you can see compared to many other
type of tissues the retinal tissue the
cell are really really packed and then
they are irregular shape and then make
it really hard to do segmentation so by
testing a variety of methods
and then we this is one of the
segmentation results we got so you can
see most of the cells can be
successfully segmented
so after segmentation then now we can
assign the individual transcript to the
cell and basically obtain the expression
profile for each cell much like the cell
gene matrix that we can get from the
single cell isaac
to use that method we can then to see
can we identify the cell major types in
the retina so as you can see from the
umap
indeed based on the murphy's transcript
profile we are able to identify all the
cell types we know in the retina
including some rare ones such as
coriander cells and rgcs
so this is basically now project put
back the cell label back to the tissue
as you can see we see the ultra nuclear
layer have primarily a rod and then some
cones on the top of the the the layer
and we can see the top half bicolor
cells as i mentioned and then they are
sprinkled with the horizontal cells and
then there's a mineral cells in the
middle and the bottom are the american
shells they have rdc at the rdc layer so
that's consistent with what we know
about the retina
so now my question our question is okay
now we can find all the major cell types
can we find the rare cell types
basically subtypes
so since the morpheus itself only has
368
probes the resolution is not very high
and so therefore we actually integrate
the norwich data with the single cell
ionization to basically take average
advantage of the high resolution single
cell isaac
can offer because we we profile large
number of cells as i mentioned the
quantum maintenance and then to see
whether we can then leverage this data
to separate you to identify different
subtypes in the mere fish so indeed as
you can see we can substitute embed
these two data together and we can find
all the bipolar cell types in morpheus
data
so not only we can find them but also
when we look at the proportion of
different subtypes the blue ones are the
cell type proportion based on the rac
and then the the orange ones based on
morpheus overall they are quite
consistent
so now we can then place all the 15
different bipolar cell type in back to
the retina as you can see very nicely
laid out
so with this data then we can explore
some
spatial relationship around them so it
has been known or people you know feel
that you know all the bipolar cell types
are distributed randomly across
so when we now is the death data and
look at systematically in fact uh i
think we find it overall it is indeed
quite uniformly or randomly distributed
however there are some subtypes about
bc1a1b which on the transmission level
is very similar they actually
closely located to each other
and they often from tablet because they
basically uh next near to to themselves
so that's in this panel you can see the
green and green and red dots they
typically form a doublet or next to each
other
well the other most of the times they
are from really random distribution
and then
we can see whether we can even have
higher resolution now by combining the
morpheus with the single cell rnc data
are for the ample cells the amine cells
is much more complex where you have more
than 60 different step types
and then you can see when we combine the
single cell isolate and work with
smurfish we can we can identify most of
them only a few clusters that cannot be
distinguished
so then we start looking at their
spatial relationship among the different
amazon cell subtypes
this most of them are sort of random
there's no particular pattern but there
are some clusters from nicely for
example this particular cluster the left
right corner
corner is colloquialized with the rgc
cells so when we look at it more closely
and what we find is there's five
different sub ampere subtypes uh uh
localized closely to rdcs so rdc itself
from a layer at the rtc layer and it's a
single cell layer and as we know that
some of the amino cells for a reason
we're not so sure about we localize from
the uh from the inner nuclear layer to
the rdc layer and those are called what
we call displacement uh displaced
american cell types as we know that
starburst african shell is the one that
displays but from based on the murphy's
data we do find those sac 13 hd17 sorry
corresponding to starburst but the other
four interesting has not been known
to be displaced and then they they are
all covered allergic
aces so their function
significance is still need to be
investigated we're in the process of
doing that
so finally we are thinking you know for
the wild types morpheus works really
really robust then we are wondering
whether it is possible to detect some
subtle differences in the mutant
situation for example and use more fish
so we we turn to this rhx three mutant
retina rh x3 is a transition factor
specifically expressed in the bipolar
cells in specifically in subsets of
bipolar cells for example bc11b
and bc6
so in our probe we did include this as a
probe as you can see in the wild type
the the expression is in the in the
nuclear layer either where the vapor
cell are
and in the natural mouse which is the
condition log of derived by 63 crate as
you can see the lhx3 expression is
largely gone you probably have maybe
five to ten percent of that
so then we
compared the morpheus results obtained
from the lrh x3 that's all right now to
the wild type overall they are very
consistent all the markers genes
essentially didn't change except that
lh2x3 is gradually dramatically reduced
so then we look at closely at the
bipolar cell types what we find is
there's two subtypes bc6 and pc1b as i
mentioned where air hx3 is expressed is
dramatically reduced this is the
quantification you can see one b is
largely reduced and is six types largely
reduced so therefore from the murphy
method we can definitely pick up those
rare cell types the change in rare cell
types
so to summary uh morpheus in our hand
seems very robust and reliable in
detecting transcript in the retinal
tissue
so vast majority of cell types can be
identified by
large amount phase with single cell rna
data
a spatial single cell data provide
interesting insight for the biology
today we did not have time to present
all of them just show you a few examples
amorphous is really sensitive in
detecting subtle changes in rare cell
types
so
for our lab we are
part of the hca project try to try to
produce a
specially resolved single transcriptome
and f general assets for human eye and
cross-gender age and ethnic groups we
are currently in covering morphage as a
major technology for that project
so we also
plan to apply morpheus to characterize
mouse and human visual system including
other parts of the eye and other than
the retina from anterior segments
posterior segments were in the process
of device developing probes and testing
it
for it
and finally
we think there's a lot of opportunity to
apply this technology to to understand
development biology the mutant and
disease tissues
so i would like to end the talk by thank
you for people who directly contributed
to the to the project uh johnny selma
jin li and then chile are student postal
in the lab who did a lot most of the
work and then this is in collaboration
with jeff and then jason jingan ken and
lingan
and this is not possible without the
collaboration with vision especially one
sec to george and jung for the help our
work is
supported by nih retinal research
foundation and the child network
initiative
with that thank you very much for your
attention and happy to answer questions
thank you dr chen for your informative
presentation
dr zhang hee director of scientific
affairs for vizgen will now join us for
the live q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
why did you choose visgen's merscope
platform over building your own mayor
fish instrument
so um
the question um so basically
i
talked in the in the talk so our primary
goal for this project to identify
all the cell types
in the retina and then put there and
also provide spatial information so
since the number of cell types in the
retina is quite large
and the proportion of them are quite
uneven so we are really looking for
something are quite sensitive
so uh by comparing the variety of
technology
we think the
essential based method are way more
sensitive than the sequencing based
method which is limited by the enzymatic
you know efficiency so that's the
primary reason and the second reason is
since the number of cells are large so
we do need a large panel
so most of the current spatial
map method uh the the sigil-based method
the number of probes are supported are
quite low like maybe 100 or 200 uh and
morpheus can uh then we support to the
500 we actually we have tried even a
panel of cells it works really well so
that's a second major
reason
and and then the third one is we are
looking for true single cell technology
uh because you know as you see the cell
subtypes are mixed together and then
they are
sort of so we do need two single cells
instead of trying to use the convolution
method to identify them which will be
very difficult so we so i think because
of the three reason why we choose more
fish as our first choice
thank you thank you
next question
how do you interpret the heat map of
spatial distribution of ac map
on the slide
slide with rgc labels the heat map
represents the abundance of the cell
subtypes or their physical distribution
yeah so the heat thanks for the question
the heat map represents how closely the
two subtypes are next to each other uh
compared to the uh by change so the more
red they are meaningless more tend to
get together so so in rdc uh you know
box so those are basically identify
the emicron cell types that are located
close to rdc types
okay
next question
who or what applications would benefit
from the insights provided by your
technology
uh
said who and what applications so i
think uh there
there's really a lot of possibilities
opened up by this technology as a
generally alluded to so uh for the start
when you try to make a reference map
right with the single cell ic you find
all the cell types and their
transcriptome profile however you don't
know how they locate it within the
tissue so uh so in the in the retina for
example we are really interested in how
the cell types are located and then also
build on on top of it then we can
potentially think about your circuit
connection connectivity so we do want to
know their spatial relationship so
that's the first that's this reference
but second i think many applications for
example the cancer situation where you
want to understand the brilliant tumor
or either boundary uh you know what
happened there you know in the retinal
situation for example if you have
retinal degeneration uh disease such as
md those are jews and deposits
people will be really interested in
understand the cells next to the lesion
versus itself far away foundation what
their behavior is so this i think this
just really a long list of things that
people can gain inside by having the
special information on top of the single
cell transcriptome you can get
thank you
next question
have you found endothelial cells or
astrocytes or microglial cells
uh so
currently our
in our
panel we didn't put those marker in
there those cells are really really rare
i think
if we put marker there we probably can
pick up the
because we do pick up
extremely rare cells but but we haven't
really tried in this particular case
all right thank you next question
how long does a single experiment take
assuming usage of the entire one
cc imaginable area including both the
imaging and hybridization washing steps
that are performed on the machine
yeah so currently our protocol it takes
about four to five days from the time
your
you know section the tissue start
hybridization and your clarion vibration
to the image
all right thank you
i'm sorry
i just want to say it you take a four
five days but you don't need to
the hands-on time is much less than that
some days just few hours some days very
fast
yeah perhaps uh this is jiang speaking
perhaps i can also add a a further note
on uh what dr chan was saying about the
image in time um so
uh for
murfish and more scope images often
divided into two phase the first phase
is sort of off the instrument sample
prep from the histology cutting to
hybridization and wash some of the
washing steps that usually takes a
couple of days to prepare the sample and
then there is a
second step which is the imaging
acquisition again for imaging one square
centimeter tissue about 500 gym panels
that usually takes about a day or so
okay great thank you
um next question
is
is the platform is there a platform to
be able to locate expression a vast
variety of different link rnas
we haven't tried it but there's no
reason why not so as long as they're the
link array sequence unique enough you
can pre-program then you should be able
to see that yes
yeah i can also add on um a little bit
because uh actually link rna unknown uh
coding rna has been uh profiled by
murphy's technology uh in the past uh so
there has been a demonstration of
murphy's imaging uh
more than 10 000 genes in cells and in
that
research paper actually
non-coding rnas were actually included
and they were able to identify quite a
number of those
non-coding rnas enriched in different
organelles or nucleus
okay thank you
next question does pfa fixed tissue
sample work similar as fresh frozen
sample and if not what are the major
differences
yeah this is probably a good question
for john i mean he's more experienced in
in this
yeah thanks adolf chen so yes so um the
murphy's protocol works for both fresh
frozen and tfa fixed frozen tissue
types and
there are two i think two key
differences uh the first
difference is that for pff fixed the
sample there's no need to fix the tissue
size anymore after cutting you can
directly go for permeabilization there
is no need for
permeabilizing um that anymore the
second key difference is in terms of the
background removal
at later step um so for murphy's
protocol the sample procedure after
hybridization and washing we do have a
autofluorescence removing step to remove
the proteins and lipids um and
uh fix the frozen tissue
because they are more cross-linked they
use a harsher
removal procedure at elevated
temperature
and in our hands we have actually
demonstrated across many different
mouth tissues that it works
very similarly for fresh frozen versus
fixed frozen sample types
thank you
next question
regarding the retinal preparation have
you tried flat mount or only cross
section
so so far we only tried a cross section
we actually tried once with the flat
mount
i think there's a lot of challenges
there
because the imaging because also
how do you you know when you try to
prepare a slide uh you know to move the
the tissue over so but i think
based on our you know one time try we
think it's possible but that means some
optimization is needed to do
that hey thank you
next question
are you planning to study ciliopathies
that affect the eye in particular bardet
beale syndrome
uh so yes we are you know as
we showed in the in the presentation you
know we we tried on the
mutant mouse so we definitely were very
interesting to look at disease human
disease eyes for example but just the
the sample availability is really
limited so but i think we really
interesting study too to follow up
thank you
next question
how critical are antibodies
to define cell boundaries
so the cell boundary uh antibody
conjugate antibodies actually we
receive directly from withdrain and they
have was three different types and then
we used all of them all of them at the
same time so uh i think in our case the
second one the channel two works the
best but not for all all the uh layers i
i do think depends on the tissue uh
maybe different type will be work better
or sometimes you probably need to use a
combination
hey thank you
next question
could you delve deeper into how murfish
allows for more robust readout than the
typical in-situ hybridization method
yeah this is actually a question for
young but based on my understanding i
can start uh it's because uh you have 30
you know
i think 30 or 50 different probes are
used
for each transcript so so the the
readout is much more robust because
because uh as long as some of them work
you will see at the second one they use
the
robust method so they can also do a lot
of error correction so we'll have much
less you know false positive um so based
on the published paper
their sensitivity side like 80 percent
uh much higher than the second cell is
around 20 percent so john do you want to
add more
sure
so yeah
you hit the point uh very well already i
i just wanted to full extent to mention
that uh murfish is actually built up on
the single molecule fish which is uh in
situ hybridization method um already
however we do have something that called
error robust barcoding and what that
really asks is that um because if you
are to sort of do single molecule fish
imaging there are chances that the
probes may sort of due to unspecific
bindings that will be false positive so
for selectives however by using this
binary barcoding scheme
and assigning each rna transcripts with
a defined barcode then even if there is
some error due to the
unspecific binding or loss of signal but
then there is ways for us to actually
detect the error and correct and that
actually makes the measurement very very
accurate and another thing that i think
sort of speaks for the sensitivity uh
and also the power of it is is that this
actually also makes it highly
quantitative that we are able to really
quantify the gene expression even for
very low expressed genes and these two
features um doesn't really compromises
dr chen was mentioned it doesn't really
compromise the detection efficiency we
still preserve that very high detection
efficiency of single molecule fish
because there are so many probes used
for a single gene
great thank you
next question
um for what type of projects would you
recommend merscope considering this is a
targeted approach as of today
so um i i think
you know the morpheus of course is
limited the majority meditation at the
motherface is right now is you
uh need to pre-design a set of probes uh
i think it's probably quite reasonable
to
to think you know up to 500 or maybe a
thousand gene will be reasonable or
relatively easy to implement or optimize
so therefore if you're looking at a sort
of discovery experiment where you really
don't know or you want to unbiased
discovery then this will be some
limitation it is possible to uh you know
you already published you can look at 10
000 you know transcript for example but
i think those
are relatively you know challenging
basically right now uh you might you
know based on my experience so um so i
think you know if it's truly discovery
this will be a little bit harder but
with that said i think by combining with
the single cell ic with smartphase you
still end up with some completional
analysis you still can basically answer
that question events for discovery
okay thank you
next question
um
why why do you think the correlation of
murfish with bulk rna sequencing was
only about 0.83 and not higher what is
the rna sequence expression measurement
used here kpkm per q
exon count or counts on the region of
murfish probe
yeah so the ra 6 is above the rna stick
it's a
full transcript rnc we happen to have
done on the mouse retina so it was down
not exact on exactly you know the uh
the same example as murphy was
conducting on so i think part of regions
could be from here and the second one is
the chemistry right so the uh the ic uh
is basically you you go through cda and
then rt process and then you know you
you're counting uh the you know
transferring per per million um and and
then from the murphy industry
essentially the count i mean it's part
of the
transcript so i think this
the main reason is probably in the
chemistry uh why it's really just
hybridization based the other is
sequence based there's some
systematic bias but overall they're
quite
[Music]
okay thank you
next question
there are not many cells in trabecular
mesh work is that possibly is it
possible to use mrscope platform
uh i yeah and it's very tiny uh you know
how to say a tiny structure yes but i
think this is murphy's is a single cell
resolution so if we do the section
and then contain the traditional
meshwork i don't think there's any
reason not be able to do it
so yeah i think the answer is yes we
should be able to do it
right
next question
how long do transcripts have to be to
allow using murfish
so
most of time you
the reason you cannot include a
transcript in the
in the probe set is because the transfer
may be
very very highly expressed in your
tissue and then because of the optical
crowding those are excluded or the
sequence are very similar like duplicate
genes but i don't think the lens will be
a limited factor because although it's
common to use 30 to 50 probes but it's
not necessary to have that many
it is possible to have just a few pro
that's my understanding john do you want
to add yeah
yeah i can add a bit on that so
currently um the uh murphy's probes are
usually designed 30 to 50 and indeed um
we sometimes even lower the amount of
probes required for targeting each gene
so
again uh
since each probe is 30 nucleotide noun
so if it's 30 new 30 probes per
gene then sort of the minimum length it
will be around 900
age and if you reduce the number of
probes then it will be
a shorter transcript
but there are strategies around to
actually uh use fewer probes for example
there has been some early demonstrations
for murfish in the literature that
actually using amplification you you
basically can use much fewer probes to
get around 400 or even short 400
nucleotides non-genes and with that then
the majority of the genes
probably will be targetable with the
amplification strategy um so these are
some of the things that uh wisdom as a
team will is still working on uh to sort
of roll out as a product but uh proof of
principle-wise it has already been
uh well demonstrated in the literature
from our technology
great thank you
next question
would you recommend the cell boundary
detection kit in less dense tissue as
well
because this is more relates to uh
wisdom's um cell boundary kit so indeed
um so less than tissues for example the
uh central nervous system like the brain
the spinal cord uh usually there's no
need for cell boundary kit because the
cells are very separate the cell body
and it's very separate from each other
so for many of those projects um that we
have seen they don't need to use
sub-understanding kit it is those tissue
where cells are very tightly packed
against each other
then the benefit of including a cell
boundary kit then really helps to define
the shape of the cell and then you get
two singles of identification
hey thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
how stringent about the platform for snp
or mini indel detection on the
transcripts
what is the dynamic range of signal
detection in terms of gea or genes with
the same set
so i think because the number of probe
people you know you can use you put down
over the transcripts large so i don't
think it's really sensitive
to you know like polymorphism you know
if you're that's some things you're
worried about so i don't think the
murphys have trouble to pick up those uh
in terms of the um
in terms of the dynamic range i think
it's
basically uh you know the lower
insensitivity low end ones you can you
can like
one transcript in the cell right so it's
very sensitive and then the hand is just
you know subject to the optical crowding
so typically in our head we then we can
see a dynamic range of you know 10 to
the fourth that's not a problem
all right thank you and thank you again
dr chen and dr he for your time today
and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor visgen for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye